let's talk about the three innate
characteristics
of women this is true of all women
doesn't matter where in the world they
are if asia
south america north america
africa australia it doesn't matter okay
um
you ask any guy that's traveled around
the world and
seen enough women in different places
the world they'll start to tell you that
they're pretty much all gonna behave in
a very similar fashion
you know there's there's always somebody
out there that's going to sell you some
narrative
like oh you got to go to this car
country or this part of the world and
they're just better there's unicorns in
this part of the world no there's just
women in a different part of the world
from a different culture
that speak a different language with
different style and different
you know societal programmings but
they're still women
women are still women they all have the
same
hard wiring you know they all have the
same firmware
and they all have the same hardware you
know on the outside when we talk about
hardware and software
anyway um yeah dudes dude saying
straight up lived in three continents
agrees
so the first characteristic the main
innate characteristic that you gotta
understand is hypergamy which
uh i've talked about before um if you
want to know all the ins and outs and
nitty-gritty of hypergamy
rolotomasi is the man to watch on that
but
the nuts and bolts of it really are is
a woman needs to believe that every day
when she gets up in the morning i mean
this is what i sum it up anyway
when she gets up in the morning that
you're the best that she can do she's
got to look at you
day in day out week in week out month
and month out year and year out and
think to herself
this dude's the best that i can do my
hypergamy's satisfied this is not what
she's thinking but
this is the mechanics of it she's
satisfied with you right she digs your
vibe
she sees you as a competent man with
skills
uh she looks at you um and thinks that
you're attractive and wants to jump your
bones
there's there's a lot of things that
come into play but that's really what
hypergamy boils down to is
is this guy the best i can do if she
starts feeling like you're not the best
that she can do and let's say i don't
know maybe kevin from sales or steve
from accountings
giving her a lot of attention and
they're handsome men
and their chads and they have like the
standard high testosterone cues chiseled
jaws deep voice you know
masculinity all that sort of stuff
and she thinks that she can do better
than you
well maybe the clock might start ticking
down i'm not saying it's going to tick
down and there's going to be an end of
the relationship
but there are a lot of things that can
start to happen which lead down towards
that
um what else can we cover with hypergamy
yeah that would be the that would be the
the like the nitty-gritty of it i mean
there's different things to consider
different times
you know different times of the month
when women are in different parts of
their cycle and there's parts of their
cycle like when they're ovulating when
they seek high testosterone cues and
more alpha cues
there's times in their cycle when
they're menstruating and they're not and
they're looking for more safety cues and
more beta bucks you know we talk about
alpha seed and beta needs so there's
little parts of hypergamy that break
down to different types
of equations but i think it's widely
accepted now
um and it's and this isn't just trp like
you know the red pill sort of stuff but
i think it's widely accepted even in evo
psych um
authors uh you know you take a look at
any of these guys that have put out some
great evo psych books
and by the way all of my recommended
books are gonna be pinned in the top
comment below so
if you're watching a replay i can't post
it before the show for some reason
anymore now they don't let you
um but always in the pin top comment of
all my videos you'll see my amazon link
and that's where i recommend
the books there's some stuff in there
from evo psych that'll blow your mind
um it's widely accepted that women are
hypergamous that's it
and don't believe any of the crap like
well men are too or men are hypogamists
or they make up some other [ __ ] to like
try to like
cope with it all it's like just
understand that
women don't like to date across
and down on the socio-economic scale
their preferences to date across
and up on the socio-economic scale
there's always some muppet that comes
out of the woodwork later on it's like
you know some comment like
i've been married for 25 years and you
know my husband makes less
than me and he was a stay-at-home dad
and i went to work and blah blah blah
it's like
all right okay let's take a look at that
because there are instances where
women do or become the bread earners
you know um they'll go out and they'll
get the bacon and she'll bring it home
and he'll cook it up sort of thing
um that does happen from time to time
but often when you look at the dynamics
of those relationships you also have to
consider
does she have any options you know like
does she have the option to leave leave
this guy
is she beautiful does she have beauty
cues is she fit like you know she
or she obese you know um there's a lot
of things to consider but
again you know what i said earlier when
i kind of started this off
this is like 95 of what you need to know
okay like there's some intricacies here
and there
which oh but there's an exception or
there's this that or the other thing
fine okay cool awesome this is again 95
of what you need to know so that's
hypergamy
you